the Joe Rogan experience yeah you know
what I'd love to MIT start growing his
cocoa plants the kind will you just chew
the leaves something you can grow them
here I'm gonna find it suitable you can
get there yeah you can make you could
you could like organize like a closet
with some heat lamps and [ __ ] do you
think yeah yeah for sure and I just have
just to like chew a little bit for a job
let's find out how many people are
growing their own coca leaves in the
United States nothing anywhere want to
well you're not why wouldn't you I would
love to think you need so much of it
that's why those cocaine right make the
Peruvian leaves I just want to bury
Marcus it's a good you chew those leaves
it's actually not bad for you at all
right and the team the coca tea is great
I've had that yeah that will settle your
nausea you know what can you specially
you get to like I'm serious like yeah
everyone starts drinking it so to sign
me up it's great isn't it crazy that
everybody just thinks to this one thing
is the processed chemicalized
[ __ ] version that Scarface and clock
me how many people have died because of
cocaine oh my god how many murders is
there another drug on the planet that is
it inspired more murders than cocaine
yeah right
I would I would love to know murders
versus number of dicks sucked for it man
if everybody got murdered every time
they did coke they don't but a lot of
people get their dicks I don't like it
might not be everybody but it's like 30%
so money that's right cuz girls can't
afford coke too if they're young and
they're partying and they're out and and
some [ __ ] guy comes along with a fat
Tracy Morgan like gold chain that's how
good coke is though yeah that's how good
it is right you that that people are
like for sure I'll just blow this
stranger oh yeah thank you it is so good
get coke that didn't do coke they would
get coke just so they have Coke so
Howard around for those four women if
girls wanted Co how cuz some girls when
they want coke they like I am calling
somebody and I'm gonna get some [ __ ]
coke I'm relieved here we want some coke
some of those you know as a guy
orgy going on somebody's just girls are
like oh I know my [ __ ] is worth stuff
so what can I get out of it what am I
looking for my brother law told me that
he went to Woodstock to you know like
what 20 years ago or whatever it was and
he said this guy got out
one of his friends got have a long life
this is Orthodox Jew got a long line
with a bunch of food like it took
forever to get through concessions and
she goes look out my way down a line
I'll blow you for that food they go yeah
let's do it Wow absolutely sucked his
dick for food yeah food sucker that's
like your chips got a little protein